Well, we were
behind each other in line
at the grocery store.
And it was silly,
but I dropped a can of peas.
And he bent over to pick them up
for me,
and that's where it started.
What can I say?
It was love at first sight.
We've been together
ever since.
Well...
Yes, she always has had
her own way of doing things.
Okay.
- I see what's going on here.
- Honey.
You don't approve
of our engagement.
- No, they're not like that.
- I'm sorry, sweetheart.
Yes, they are like that.
Look at their faces.
There's no point
in trying to reason with folks
who can't appreciate
the differences in others.
You should be ashamed
of yourselves.
[somber music]
Honey, wait.
[door closes]
I cannot believe that
you would bring a colored man
into our house.
♪ ♪
[sobs]
[crying]
He's gone now.